well the raiders lost a heartbreaker in
overtime last night to the chargers but
in the defeat there was an unexpected
bright spot
from a fan favorite john treach has the
story about the qb who filled in
admirable
admirably john that's right marcus
mariota's career feels like a country
song once upon a time
he was the greatest young football
player in the world but injuries
inconsistencies
and a crisis of confidence led to him
being benched in tennessee released
and a forgotten backup in las vegas but
ironic in the christmas season fans saw
a raider resurrection
in the final two minutes of the first
quarter derek carr ran for the end zone
and then limped into the locker room
he clutched at his groin a special kind
of pain even in a pandemic
there was not a lot of hope in marcus
mariota filling in the former oregon
duck took the field for the first time
since week six of last season mariota
wasn't good he was spectacular
accounting for over 300 yards and two
touchdowns the raiders relied on the 27
year old and he rewarded them
you know to be truthful it's been a long
journey
you know i've been through kind of
everything from injuries to surgeries to
you know mental kind of just lapses and
you know the the confidence thing and um
you know i just truly appreciate
the raiders and the entire organization
for kind of helping me through that
um you know i was trying to
kind of find my way again and um you
know they gave me an opportunity
kind of take some time you know they're
patient with me and you know i just
appreciate the fact that they
were willing to do that mariota signed
an
incentive-laden contract his strong play
last night earned him
825 000 alone so if you're marcus's
sister and get a 10
gift card to starbucks for christmas he
has some explaining to do
kirsten